hello everyone I had a lot of requests
for this game so here it is this is
around three of the Isle of Man
international tournament
James star John versus Vladimir Kramnik
and well James or John was a was a
promising Grandmaster in the 70s he was
a he was a member of the Olympic team
for the United States and well in 1984
he gave up chess to become a librarian
but no one really ever gives up on chest
completely so here he is playing in
round 3 against the former world
champion Vladimir Kramnik and this was a
pretty big upset as John is rated around
2,400 and while chronic is ready to
round 2800 so so there is a 400 kilo
points difference and I will put a link
in the description below where you can
check out team Jettas interview with
James Turner John it's quite enjoyable
I encourage you to watch it so let's see
this game third John is white and the
big Vlad is black we have c4 Knight to
f6 g3 c6 Knight to f3 d5 be three in
Bishop to g4 micronic Bishop to g2e six
star John castles Knight bt7 Bishop to
b2 and we can see that there John
already feel shadowed both of his
bishops and this was kind of his plan
because how do you prepare against a
player like Kramnik well you have the
white pieces this seems like the most
optimal setup you just you know you try
and hold everything together so Bishop
to d6 then we have b3 kramnik castles
and that b d2 rook to e8 h 3 bishop to
h5 rook to e1 a5 by Kramnik a 3 and now
a 5 and already you can see that black
doesn't really black it doesn't really
have any problems here in development
this bishop is this Bishop on h5 is ok
he can even go to g6 where he will be a
bit more active this Bishop on d6 is
beautiful after after E 4 will be played
at some point
chromic is doing okay here seek after 75
when we have seek address on b5 and
night to h4 by James Knights the c5 we
have Queen to c2 Knights the e6 and rook
a to C 1 and we have 9 goes to D D for
Queen to d1 as the Queen was attacked
and night the b5 attacking that a3 pawn
and night the b1 defending the a3 pawn
turjun doesn't mind putting the night on
b1 as he is playing against Vladimir
Kramnik we have Queen to d7 King to h2
heading protection to this pawn on h3
and our up to a 6 from Nick's idea is
well he will put this Bishop on b8 and
well depending on the position he will
either double up rooks here or maybe in
the future even rugby g6 or rock age 6
so we have a nice back to f3 and we have
a 4 by pranic and now this dark square
Bishop comes alive we have D captures on
e4 and here chronic plays and Knight
captures on e4
James now John said that if chronic had
played this D captures on e4
he has planned the knight to h4 and then
F if chronic decided to push III then f4
and he said that he thought this was
okay for white no problems there but
after D captures only for chronic played
Knight captures on e4 and we have rook
to f1 by James of course you can't
capture this pawn on d5 because Bishop
captures on g3 loses the Queen just to
get that out of the way so rook to f1
adding protection to this f2 pawn we
have Bishop to b8 some not Kramnik as
well he has ideas of rooty 6 maybe g6 or
h6 will see Knight to c3 the James would
love to exchange a feral nights we have
Knight captures Bishop captures and now
a chronica decides to double up rooks on
e-file we have a bishop to be 1 also
turjun seems to be putting all of his
pieces on the last rank on the first
rank he said that he was even
considering night to g1 to protect the
e2 poem like this so we have 86 by
kramnik Wow
this h6 move wasn't really ambitious as
this prevents this from ever coming to
h6 and the King wasn't really in danger
there on the last rank so this breeding
Square that isn't really doing that much
for black rook to c2 improving the
position a bit adding some protection to
the e2 pawn bishop to a7 and we have
Queen to C 1 preparing moves like a rook
to c7 maybe so Bishop to b6 not allowing
Roxy 7 we have III Queen to b5 attacking
the b3 pawn and here at well this is the
critical moment of the game here Kramnik
is cronikeys doing okay he's even better
with a move like rook to f6 adding more
pressure to the knight on f3 this would
be completely okay for black but chronic
played to this Queen to b5 move okay he
is attacking the b3 pawn but he's
allowing this nice to d4 idea and now
the night is attacking the Queen and the
rook on d6 so Bishop captures on d6
he captures and e6 and now we have well
now chronic should play a very nice move
for example b6 is a move Bishop to e2 is
a move but chronic goes for the kill
he plays Bishop to f3 and this seems to
be giving up the bishop entirely and
okay I do I did understand this move
first time I saw it I thought okay can't
capture the bishop because Queen
captures on f1 is coming but James
decided to capture the bishop and the
well here I thought okay very nice
Kramnik wins the rock but actually
chronic played the Knights to g3
because what's the idea if
captures rook on f1 then this is the
moon kramnik missed he missed
Bishop to e2 and this is a well this is
trapping the Queen but I think well I
think this can actually be played this
would have been much better than what
chronic actually played if you continue
this with Knight captures on g3 and
sacrifice the Queen Bishop captures an
f1 Knight captures an f1 this is what
you check so King to g2 and now rook
captures on e1 now attacking the Queen
and after a move like Queen to be to
rook to e6 you're threatening rook to g6
and well rook to see it check King to h7
and wrote to c3 and now rook to g6 and
now well James would have to give up
this rook with rook to g3 because if you
don't give up the rook for example if
you play it something like King to f3
you get check mated with night to h2
check so King at for the rook to e4
check can get 5 and roof to g5 this is
checkmate
so after this rook to g6 tarragon would
have would have been forced to play
something like rook to g3 and give up
the rook 9 captures F captures and well
Kramnik is upon up and two rooks are
well always better than a queen this
would have been the winning for chronic
although I might have missed something
but I don't think I have but yeah after
this Bishop to f3 chronic didn't capture
the rook he played Knight captures on g3
and after F capture some g3 now he
captured the rook and now it seems like
his either grabbing this pawn this
Bishop on f3 or this Bishop anyone but
he doesn't get either because Bishop to
f2 is is what star John played and not
to crown x4 well tear John has two
bishops so he has a bishop pair for a
rook and it wouldn't do chromic much but
if he was rated 5000 this is well this
is this position is too good for white
Quinta d3 was played I rocked the c3
Queen to a5
King to g2
we have roped the f6 try to exchange
Queens Queen c2 Queen d7 dodgy for rock
the c6 and now rock the c5 rock the d8
and ah Queen to f5 forcing the exchanger
Queens a chronic place rock captures on
c5 Queen captures d7 recaps 27 and
alkalyn captures on c5 and now the
bishop pair is simply dominating this
rook we have before King f1 d3 kinky 1b
to check King d1 chronic tries to bring
the King into the game or rook at this
Bishop to g3 King g7 not check King e6
grabbing the pawn a couple of more moves
and well this B point is just marching
up the board and in this position I
believe it was where one me kramnik
resigned as there are no more moves if
he play something like King to c7 simply
Bishop to a7 and well black can't stop
this b8 Queen move and well later white
can simply even sacrifice this Bishop
for this pawn and this point is going to
become a queen or he can just play it
simple and grab all the points he's King
this much closer so yeah after b7 will
require me to resign the game and Jim
star John is definitely the hero of the
Isle of Man tournament so far maybe
maybe there will be more upsets we'll
see so yeah that's it
I do hope you enjoyed the game as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you all for watching and I
will see you soon and thank you all for
a very nice messages I will I am trying
to get the better see you soon guys